la realidad de la pandemia se ha
impuesto a la voluntad política en
francia emmanuel macro ni el primer
ministro jan castex no querían imponer
un nuevo confinamiento pero el aumento
de contagios y de la presión
hospitalaria especialmente en la región
de parís llevó a decretar el pasado
jueves 18 al menos cuatro semanas de
confinamiento en 16 departamentos
incluido parís en alemania angela merkel
decretó nuevas restricciones para semana
santa tras una reunión de 11 horas con
los jefes de gobierno de los 16 estados
federados ante lo que describió como una
situación sanitaria preocupante por esta
razón se declaran como días de descanso
el 1 y el 3 de abril con grandes
restricciones en los contactos y la
prohibición de reuniones del 1 al 5 de
abril es un período de descanso
prolongado durante semana santa
y ambos países han enfrentado protestas
de ciudadanos y sectores económicos por
el endurecimiento de las restricciones
reino unido- pese a tener la vacunación
más adelantada en europa sigue sin tener
la certeza de cuándo se relajarán las
medidas de confinamiento al otro lado
del atlántico en américa latina' el
alcalde de río de janeiro anunció el
cierre de actividades no esenciales
durante 10 días el número de personas
que esperan una cama uci a aumento de 63
a 493 y el sistema sanitario amenaza con
colapsar en la capital de un país que
suma ya casi 300.000 muertes por kobe 19
y vamos viviendo probablemente la
situación más crítica de esta pandemia
estamos muy preocupados por esta
situación y las cosas están ocurriendo
muy rápido chile por su parte volverá a
confinar a más de 13 millones de
personas desde el jueves 25 la medida se
anunció este lunes tras el aumento del
17 por ciento de los contagios en la
última semana el domingo se confirmaron
siete mil 84 casos en 24 horas la cifra
más alta de la pandemia pese a ser el
tercer país del mundo con mayor tasa de
vacunación por cada 100 habitantes